it was an intense evening of TV as the  battle rounds on The Voice heated up and  Rihanna continued to sizzle on Bates  Motel which delivered an epic twist  [Music]  you  [Music]  I can't dance Oh  that's hunter Plake battling it out  against David Cassidy's nephew jack on  Monday's episode of The Voice both  contestants slayed but coach Alicia Keys  could only pick one the winner of this  battle  is Jack but there's more good news both  Adam Levine and Gwen Stefani tried to  steal hunter I really think that I need  a pic went over on Bates Motel  Rihanna kept things sexy as she  recreated the iconic shower scene from  psycho but plot twist  Marian didn't die her boyfriend Sam  Loomis on the other hand did  [Music]